it had been predicted by some feared by
many more
but european leaders see russia's move
to halt gas supplies to poland and
bulgaria because they won't pay in
rubles as aggressive it comes as no
surprise
that the kremlin uses fossil fuels to
try to blackmail us
this is something the european
commission has been preparing for in
close coordination and solidarity with
member states and international partners
our response will be immediate
united and coordinated
moscow says countries can still pay for
gas imports in euros or dollars but only
if they open russian bank accounts which
then convert the currency and make the
final payment it's thought some
countries have already done so
but bulgaria which gets the vast
majority of its gas supplies from
gazprom is not one of them
we will not succumb to such a racket
bulgaria is reviewing all agreements
with gazprom including the agreement on
gas transit through bulgaria because
one-sided blackmail is not acceptable
the polish president has promised to
take legal action but the prime minister
is insisting there's no immediate threat
saying storage facilities are
three-quarters full higher than in most
of europe
as i've emphasized many times poland had
previously prepared to diversify
supplies and obtain gas from various
sources even before the baltic gas
pipeline is launched we'll be able to
protect our economy to protect polish
households from such a dramatic step by
russia
some warsaw residents if not all seem
reassured
this man says shutting down gas supplies
might end up harming russia he says his
country has reserves
while this woman wonders how much polls
like her will have to pay for
developments linked to the ukraine war
saying things are already incredibly
expensive
the eu's biggest economy germany has
been the most reluctant to end gas
imports from russia but on wednesday it
said it was speeding up efforts to find
alternatives including liquefied natural
gas
i can say that our russian gas
dependency which was at 55 before the
war and dropped to 40 a few weeks ago is
now at 35 percent
so for now the common message is there's
no need to panic but it's hard to say
how russia's move will play into the
existing energy price crisis across
europe nadeem baba al-jazeera
russian president vladimir putin says
ukraine was pushed to clash with russia
and moscow's reaction was just and fair
speaking to politicians in st petersburg
he warned that any country that
interferes in ukraine will face
consequences
if anyone would want to interfere with
what's happening in ukraine now from the
outside they have to know russia's
response will be swift and fast we have
all sorts of tools that the west cannot
obtain and we will not boast of our
weapons but we will use them if need be
and i want everyone to know that
has this update from moscow
the russian president is not um
really passing up this opportunity to
reiterate the reasons that he felt it
was necessary for him to make the
decision
to send the russian troops into ukraine
in what he calls a special military
operation that is now in its 63rd day
vladimir putin as we just heard i had a
very strong and stern warning for those
countries that are assisting ukraine in
the fight against the russian troops he
said that they're basically a fair game
for the russians and that they this is a
fight between russia and ukraine and
that's the third countries that are
getting involved really
have no right to do so and that
he feels that he will be
forced to make a decision as to whether
or not to use all the tools that are at
his disposal to ensure a victory for the
russian military now vladimir putin was
also
speaking quite a bit about the
objectives that he set out for his
legislative officials about ensuring
that russia's economy stays intact and
he said that the attempts that have been
made by the
western powers to
try to [ __ ] russia's economy through
severe sanctions have failed and that
russia is standing still
and they are not going to
allow its economy to crumble he also
urged the officials that he was speaking
to he said to they have to work on
anti-crisis measures and also they have
to strengthen the country's sovereignty
there's a lot of emphasis on trying to
basically ensure that russia's economy
stays strong and that the ruble doesn't
plummet like it did a few weeks ago
what's happening on the battlefield and
mario paul city officials say russia
continues to strike the last remaining
ukrainian army positions there with 35
aerial hits since monday
thousands of ukrainian fighters and
civilians are in underground tunnels and
chambers below the azov style steel
plant
last week vladimir putin ordered troops
not to storm the plant but blockaded
russia agreed in principle to allow the
u.n and the red cross to help evacuate
civilians from the steel plant and
mariopol after putin's meeting with the
u.n secretary general on tuesday
in the mario poll direction the enemy is
exerting massive fire and blocking our
units in the area of the avestar plant
in the city occupiers continue to carry
out filtration measures against the
civilian population
and there have been protests in key of
demanding safe humanitarian corridors
out of the other style steel plant
mothers and wives of soldiers fighting
in mariopol attended the demonstrations
agreements between ukraine and russia to
allow safe passage of fighters and
civilians have failed so far
ukrainian forces are also confronting
the russian military in the east
fierce fighting has been reported in
makolayev and hassan in the southeast
russian forces also shelled the town of
lyman
in southern ukraine the russian
militaries fired tear gas and stun
grenades at protesters in the city of
kharsam
people are rallying against what they're
calling a sham referendum ukraine says
russia is planning to hold a staged vote
in the kharsan region try and show
popular support for the creation of a
russian-backed republic
hassan is occupied by russian troops and
residents have been protesting against
their presence for weeks